okay there's plans committee meeting
with the 4th of November welcome to
anybody who's watching on the Tories
YouTube
um question on our agenda is apologies
for absence
yes thank you chair one apology thanks
to the Watson councilor Pennington
substituting
thank you welcome to council Pennington
again thank you good to be here likely
to be full-time
[Music]
um and before I go on because at the
last meeting I was a bit late into it
was to ask the plans committee and
officers who are here this morning to
introduce themselves so I'll start and
Chris leather
and I representing all of them and then
I'll call Richard good morning my name
is Peter Christie and I represent Bishop
North good morning my name is Rosemary
knock and I represent two rivers and
three Wars good morning I'm councilor
Margaret Brown and Robert can present
great Torrington
good morning I
represent Harvard
hi I'm Ruth crazy
Philip Pennington locally and putford
Richard Wiseman I represent shabir and
Langtry Ward
and then on my left Helen Smith I'm
planning manager at torridge Council
Stacey Dory and head of legal
governments
Nora Davis development management team
leader
good morning all I'm Matthew military
Environmental Protection Officer
authorization Council
good morning Sandra Democratic Services
officer good morning Kirsty Democratic
Services officer that's everybody lovely
thank you what can we move on to item
two on the agenda which is the minutes
of the last meeting held on the 6th of
October on pages 5 to 18 of your agenda
and I'll move those from the chair
in the minutes it doesn't mention I
think we broke for language
because the impression we met for five
hours without a break which I think
well we didn't mean there was a break
because whether we sat here and had a
nice lunch but okay thank you I mean
making Amendment it's just to record
that we didn't break down I think it
should I missed that let myself well
thank you
okay
on the page to uh item three on the
agenda oh sorry those on these minutes
that's film throwing their clothes
but I recommended for approval with that
Amendment and councilor lock sector
[Music]
Brown councilor Christie or councilor
craigie abstain because I wasn't there
thank you cancel the leather for
potentially locks four councilor wise
man or a council Pennington four thank
you thank you Sandra right now we'll
move on to item three which is
Declarations of Interest
then was really interested to declare
should refer to the agenda eigen and
describe the nature of their interest
when the item is being considered
elected members of Devon County Council
and town and Parish councils who've
considered a planning application by
virtue of their membership of that
Council all the personal interests and
are deemed to have considered the
application separately
I'm interested views of that council do
not bind the Masters concerned who
consider the application afresh and I
always add in there that it's only at
this meeting that we get older than that
last minute uh updates and
clarifications so very often parish and
temp councilors don't have every scrap
of information that we do have with the
commitment
to agree the agenda between Parks one
and two there is no part two
they can find an urgent matters in
information I have nothing to bring
forward
[Music]
so then we move on to item six on the
agenda which is public participation
and we've had three
applications this morning eight members
of the public plus Council adult to
speak there's
Steve Smith speaking to the first one at
parkham member of the public against
cancel it down it will speak as well as
a board member there and
that's those two for the particle one
then for Coastal cabins at Heartland
we've got Grand matter against speaking
against them
um Melissa shelves in support member of
the public
Graham Townsend who's the agent for the
applications
member of the public
against
we've got Anthony Wade
with an email to be read out by a
planning manager
we've got Walter won a cup in support
who's the agent for that application and
then finally Joel Tucker for the benefit
Business Park East the water a member of
the public speaking against
and so
we've not been to a plans meeting before
or those those watching on YouTube
it's expected that only return the plan
committee that they'll give a fair and
uninterrupted hearing to the planning
officer giving their report and to all
those listed to speak and to the
planning committee members when they
begin their consideration after all it's
only common occur to say thank you and
the Order of speakers is as followers
the planning officer will give that
presentation of the application and then
any town or Parish Council
representative who wishes to speak for
or against the application they have
three minutes each
and then up to two members of the public
speak to members of the public speakers
who wish to speak against they get three
minutes each to address the committee
and then up to two public speakers in
support of an application and they get
three minutes each as well and then
finally any tourist district council
member from the ward in which the
application Falls uh that they can
address the committee in the meeting
and then the plans committee will debate
the application with any questions that
they may have the appropriate officer
okay
so we move on to item seven on the
agenda which is planning applications
the information
recommendations and advice contained in
the reports are correct the date of
preparation which is more than 10 days
in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes or necessary updates to the
reports will be provided in writing or
Aura at the committee meetings
and we start with our first application
7A which is the one at Park and
and Laura here to present this
[Music]
thank you chair
the application uh seeks full Planning
Commission for the addition of five
dwellings at Parkin
and the application site is located
immediately to the north of some days
it's close in terms of the red line and
to the western side of the village of
Parkin for reference to members the
settlement boundary in the policies
match for the local plan extends on the
southern boundary of site and along the
road to the east so the applications are
Edibles outside of his village
uh he was an aerial photograph on the
next slide that Andrew is my crude Red
Line there which is for members just to
be able to orientate with the rest of
the village and showing the relationship
to the existing built form there and
then the following one just to sort of
zoom in and show the site so it's one
parcel of the sort of yellow Earth field
that you can see there
we have a post site plan showing five
detached dwellings
including two Bungalows plus four and
five to the South and then three Chalet
Bungalows to the northern Parks we have
a new access being formed onto the
public Highway
and there'll be a new hedge Bank being
formed in the northern and western
boundaries uh
to separate the site often from the
surrounding field
and we would have translocation of the
Pedro along the frontage to form the
visibility display and you see there's a
path leading from the access to the
South linking into the rest of the
village
move through the plans uh show a fairly
traditional design for the properties
and as I said before summer I've got
accommodation within the roof slopes um
our Bungalows and where it includes a
mix of render and cladding and brickwork
to the elevations with their
dark gray tiles to read slopes so we'll
just run through the
different house types of amazing
nice
photographs that members may recall from
the site visit and are you looking South
across the sites the properties you can
see there are the ones in St James Place
directly across the across the site to
the existing built form
and then looking along the eastern
boundary in the existing hedge Bank we
have there
and then a viewer across the site sort
of Southwest
um you've got some James dice properties
on the left-hand side of the photograph
and then the newer properties that have
been recently built on Melbourne road
which are shown sort of the whiter ones
to the central picture
and then a view the members showing the
view to the West so looking out to The
Wider landscape from the application
site is existing and then a view along
the adjacent Highway where the new
access would be formed
so just to run through the material plan
considerations I set up report
the principle of developments and the
application site is located outside of
the settlement boundary Village but it's
fully assessed in the officers report
within the context of policy st21 due to
the current lack of by the housing land
Supply
uh number two the impact on landscape
character and appearance uh the sites
includes a more open aspect as existence
in the north and west with adjacent
development of the South we've got a
mature hedge back to the east
the edge of settlement location would
result in the development being seen in
the context of the existing Village from
wide abuse from the west of the key area
that you would be able to get that wider
View
the designers scale
of the base buildings is considered to
be similar to those at some James close
and therefore no objections are raised
in terms of landscape character and
appearance
um touching on historic character and
the nearby Church within the village
it's great to style listed
and the application site is considered
to be born part of the wider setting of
the church when viewed from the
landscape to the West we've had a
consultation response from historic
England which raises no objections and
we've also had comments from our
Conservation Area a conservation officer
um who doesn't consider that the
development would impact on the setting
of the church any further than the
recently approved Bungalows to the south
west
and so she's raised no objection in
terms of the setting impact on the
setting of ballistic building
uh the impact on residential amenities
as you see from photographs the nearest
neighboring residents are in St James
close uh the officers report provides a
detailed assessment of the relationship
between the proposed and existing
properties and due to the distance
between those and The Limited height in
their design a harmful impact isn't
considered to result
I'm also consider that the proposed site
plan would include sufficient space for
future occupiers of the developments
uh the council's Environmental
Protection Officer has commented on the
proposals there's recommended conditions
in relation to construction working
hours and unexpected contamination and
those are included in the recommendation
so we have no no objections in terms of
presidential amenities
accessing parking
each dwelling would have its own garage
and parking spaces and we'd have a new
access onto the highway the county
council's highways officers raise no
objection subject to a number of
conditions including those to ensure the
visibility display is provided on site
in terms of drainage the bowel drainage
would be discharged into the mains and
surface water drainage would be
discharged by an attenuation Basin
um to the southwest of the site from
Land within the applicant's control
ecology and ecological impact assessment
has been submitted in support of the
application and it notes the loss of
part of the existing hedge Bank to allow
for new access
that concludes that this would be
largely of what would be offset by the
creation of a significant length of new
Hedgerow to the north and to the west of
the site and then further mitigation and
enhancement measures are also
recommended including timing of works
and the inclusion of battle and birth
boxes within the developments
section 106 and a legal agreement would
be sought to secure contributions
towards additional Secondary School
infrastructure and also the cost of
transporting people to the nearest
Secondary School
and contributions would also be sought
towards provision of off-site green
infrastructure within Parkland
so in terms of the planning balance the
application site isn't located in a
protected area
and it's considered that the adverse
of the proposed development was not
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of The Proposal when
assessed against the policies of the
legal plan as a whole along with those
of the mppf
and having considered all of the various
planning issues as a result the
recommendation is for approval thank you
thank you Laura for that and a
presentation
our first contributor to this this
morning is Steve Smith a member of the
public speaking against that to come up
to the microphone and what she said and
you've got three minutes to address the
connected
thank you
foreign
[Music]
houses as we know but it needs to be
viewed in The Wider context
there were 150 houses in Parkland
Village in 2019 since then have been
another 57 houses built or in progress
including this application they refer
the 28 proposed
this represents a staggering 57 increase
in houses in less than three years
57 percent
this increase is neither balanced nor
sustainable moreover it's changing the
very character of Parts as a village
forever we need to maintain the
character of The Village
the proposed development would result in
harm associated with policy st07
the council space and strategy for Rural
affairs
there is no perceived need for these
five Bungalow as well as the price range
of many local residents
we held an unofficial referendum in
December last year and 84 percent of
villagers voted against further
development we feel we've contributed
more than our fair share to the
Torrington North Devon housing stock
already the impact and pressure on
infrastructure is immense parking has
very difficult access we've only got
single track roads going into the
village yet due to lack of amenities
travel away from the village is
necessary there are limited
opportunities for employment virtually
no public transport and the village
sewage treatment works are operating at
full capacity
the proposed development is outside the
north Devon and Torres local plan
members of this planning committee will
be aware that in May this year Sean
Harrington the previous planning manager
stated that this proposed development
does not recorder that Provisions the
development plan enforce in the area
indeed highways committed in June
the parking Village is currently subject
to significant levels of Housing
Development and the cumulative impact
has not been considered as required by
paragraph 113 in the National planning
policy framework an objection was
therefore raised by highways
traffic movements were increased from
the 110 000 to 166
000 per annum
this the planning committee report for
this application mentions that the
developer would provide support for the
services and Facilities Department This
is highly unlikely one of the properties
would be occupied by the landowner and
has restated the rural Villages minimal
services and Facilities
so far development in partner has been
piece now with no overall plan surely we
need to assess the impact of the 57
houses being built or in progress before
further mudding the Water by building
more
Park and Parish Council and Parkland
Community Group therefore strongly
recommend refusal of this application
thank you
right our next contributor is speaking
this is councilor and adult
foreign
[Music]
thank you for allowing me to speak
you may be wondering why I have called
this application before you after all
it's only five dwellings and he is quite
straightforward on Facebook however this
site is a departure from the local plan
its cumulative effect along with the
countless other applications in recent
years is creating an accounting strain
on local infrastructure it is changing
the essence of Parkin and this is
concerning to many residents who feel
enough is enough
the site will take agricultural land and
replace it with housing we need food as
much as we need housing the five
dwellings on this site are unlikely to
be affordable for local families
this is demonstrated in the Devon County
Council funding for Education requests
1.25 primary pupils and 0.75 secondary
pupils
five dwellings
two pupils
the transportation statement Pierce have
commissioned quotes the mppm supporting
developments that provide properties for
families for young children
this site does in theory yet in reality
the chances of families with young
children being able to afford the open
market value of these houses is at best
unlikely
the mppf is also quoted as promoting
social interaction through mixed-use
developments I don't see next use on
this site
I do know though that Matthew military
prefers in his report to phase one
maybe we will see the mixed use being
brought forward when the remainder of
the field comes more of the development
in say phases two three even four I'm
surmising I appreciate the constraints
that as committee you have to make your
decisions by however I was elected to
represent the whole of Parkin so that is
everyone and to ensure that everyone has
a voice
that is democracy after all as the
parish council has just started the
process of producing its own
neighborhood plan the only mechanism
currently to counter the Relentless
barrage of building sites is to bring
them to your attention for absolute
scrutiny and assessment
which is what I shall now leave you to
debate thank you for your time thank you
Council
[Music]
right well that's the last of our
contributions to this application
I wouldn't say to the rest of
Connecticut and you all realize that
this is outside the development family
for parking and had this lack of the
five-year housing allowances line not
being in the place this would certainly
never a gas Master at all it would have
been refused the other thing is it is
for me looking at the spatial strategy
plan for Parkin contrary to that because
in that the park and spatial strategy it
does mention a provision
of a minimum let's try a minimum of 15
new dwellings to meet a range of housing
needs in the community
the supply of housing will be delivered
through a single site allocation and
you've heard any I think you all know
because we've heard it before the
terrific increase of building that's
gone in Parkin over the last couple of
years
um
I'll leave it my comments at that for
now but
the one thing about highways in the area
I think you all know
the roads in the area around the parking
lot the life and as one of our speakers
mentioned comics from highways back in
June but there was a subsequent one
um in July from the 6th of June to the
27th of July the change from a
recommendation of refusal without a
proper transport statement or assessment
as required by the nppf to
one of the increasing traffic that will
result from this proposal will make
things more inconvenient for drivers on
the local Road well I think it probably
makes it a bit more than inconvenient
added to all that's been developed in
that area but I'll leave my comments
about you know who else would like to
many comments
Council of
yeah I was just going to mention the
um
difference from the
um highways that is it would be more
inconvenient but there's no evidence to
support a reason for refusal I mean I
didn't spend
I shouldn't be ashamed to take what a
few times in park it would be frequently
but on a Sunday so I drive in fact I was
driving through Parker yes um last week
um I do have to say that it is outside
the development boundary but when you
look at all the tons of D's
um responses the Environmental
Protection officers have got nerves
um objections subjects and the
construction letters the cognization has
got no objectives there is a
um a dispute with the land ownership but
that is not the material consideration
um I've just got one query on page 33
section 106 payments it's 21 000 for
off-site the quick player area and then
three thousand seven hundred and eleven
pound towards Mains of this area is that
a one-off ranger that's payment or is
that a yearly maintenance payment
s
repayment and a maintenance payment
associated with each element of
agreement structure contributions
so um
we've got to apply the deal to balance
I know it's outside the
um development boundary but I would
recommend that the application is
approved as per the officers report
and it comes along comes the ground
thank you Council around
one thing that occurs to me well Council
Ox mentioned the one on six agreement or
is the secondary education
infrastructure of 17 tires or 600 to
Great Torrington School the nearest
Secondary School to this site is the
Atlantic Academy
perhaps they've forgotten about the
Atlantic economy because it also in this
proposed section 106 is 3 300 pound
scores transport and I would have
thought if
the Atlantic Academy which I don't think
is for the staff
was from is full of pupils I think that
should be addressed before anyone on six
is saying so
whether it is great torrent in school
with all the transport involved for
pimples together it's a long way off
compared to the academy the other thing
that I noticed too in the
bargain strategic character
plan is
it no tear that the Jewish treatment
plan that was mentioned I think the
village sewage treatment plant works
in Opera is operating close to capacity
and investigations into the need for
improvements will be required prior to
the release of new sites for the
development for development now I did
mention at our site visit I'd likely a
bit from South West Water
have these improvements ever been
carried out there because all the
additional housing that's come on over
the last two or three years that we've
heard about
obviously has a significant impact on
serious treatment and this is another
five going into that same level you
found in it you know
I have counselor yes so I've contacted
Southwest water and asked for a bit more
clarification about this and then to our
site visit
um
they have commented the fact that with
regards to capacity any new development
has the right to connect to any suitably
sized public asset in the vicinity
the owners is then on Southwest water to
maintain and improve Services where
necessary to cope with any increase in
volume
so effectively at Southwest water that
would need to improve the facilities if
additional development comes forward
well we've all we've had a heard
alternatives to that on sites that the
applicant has to improve the system if
anything needs Improvement and that
doesn't answer the question anyway
whether they've ever done any
since the lamb was formulated whether
they're increased the capacity of the
treatment plan that's all that we'd like
to know about to be honest
[Music]
a couple of things um Atlantic Academy I
think it's 120 students there at home
meant to have 700 but I thought they
were a certain year groups rather than a
whole school I'm not sure about that but
anyway
um
go back to uh this application
um I I must say I I was intrigued by the
Council of darts uh calling where it
says I wish to call the above
applications of committee for
contemplation
um
I've been contemplating it hard I have
to say
um
I was intrigued because if you look in
our agenda today you'll find that the
site opposite of this which was a 17
houses was actually rejected and I've
read through what what that rejection is
based on
um there's basically
um
three points versus the impact on the
nearby church and this of course is
further away from the church so
unfortunately that doesn't stand without
constellation pointed out the secondly
it's about flooding
and again
uh it doesn't seem to stack up
the the site opposite had problems this
site they seemed to have signed it off
the
utilities
um but I'll go back to the sewage
because as you know I've got the council
to write to Southwest water and just
asked about this entire question about
capacity and as you pointed out chairman
that answer was ridiculous I mean we all
know that cornbread must be
uh overcharged because of all the sewage
it keeps being delayed in these Village
sites I now hear that you know it's
close to capacity but that's all right
because you can connect it anyway and
we'll sort it out later
um I just find that unacceptable whether
it's grounds or not to turn this down
because I noticed Southwest water
haven't said no uh I really don't know
but can I ask the opposite if we turn
this down today it goes to appeal what
are the chances of them winning
statutory continues have said no
well given we've had no objections then
we're unlikely to have any support from
those utilities companies at an appeal
so if we would need to provide evidence
yeah go just wait one more
if you look at this road that goes
outside they're going to access I find
it astonishing the highways so there's
no problem
um they seem to be washing their hands
of this all over the place we've had it
so many times now where we as councilors
we can see there are problems but the
highway apparently can't
um I just find that inexplicable
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the development of this site and
potentially the one at the bottom which
is already draining into it so the
owners of the property will have to come
to an agreement
it's either a management company amongst
the owners or is the existing landowner
so is there any risk of overflow or to
the adjoining properties that go out
towards
capsule cross
um when there's heavy rain is there a
risk there of of
flooding and immediately not on the site
but away from the site but affecting
other people
there shouldn't be because it should be
built to a certain standard regulations
will have a role in that in terms of
ensuring the capacity is correct
okay so so so the word is that it's
built to such a there will be no
fluttering there
but they shouldn't be but that's the way
it should be constructed
thank you chair of course
agriculture Pennington Council wise
we'll talk cricketer
um I have a great deal of services start
from what's being said by the public
here you see uh this morning 57 increase
in um in housing in the village
um it's happening everywhere Now isn't
it and we're handed down these um these
housing figures and we have to make sure
we comply and we're outside of our
five-year housing allocations we all
know so we might not like it
our situation is and that so that's not
ground
um
we've also learned a lot about the
sewerage situation that that apparently
it's close to capacity I don't know what
that means to be honest but we put it
here in in black and white and the
replying from Southwest water they have
no concerns and it's their
responsibility to make sure it works
promptly and that's not for it so that's
not really a consideration of this
committee because take into account
either I'm looking for some reasons to
turn this down I can't
honestly so I can find any and we've got
to treat everybody with an even hand and
apply the rules equally and evenly
wherever so I can't see any grounds to
vote against this personally
yeah thank you Council Wiseman and I'll
just go back to that series one because
when this plan was formulated the
current local plan was formulated that's
where the comments came from about the
village sewage treatment works is
operating close to capacity which means
to me not much more could be added to it
without significant or work done to it
now I did ask at the same visit and
Laura's answered the response she's
having sex with water we don't know if
that capacity has been expanded at all
but we do know of the 50 old houses 57
built since this plan was formulated and
another 28 that's written
language to be in construction an
increase of 57 in the village of Parkins
a huge increase without knowing whether
the serious treatment works have ever
had any work done
and we we were told in the past by
Southwest water applicants have to
improve any system if it's necessary to
make an application acceptable but this
counselor Christie said and I I don't
agree with that statement it's no use of
overloading a system and then said well
we'll we'll sort it out now we've had
sewage flooding in the area so it gets
sort of depth you know
with I think this committed over the
last few meetings about issues about the
lack of information from South West
water and the other thing was
um yeah the housing land Supply
situation doesn't negate the rest of our
planning policies because it is
comparatively new plan that origin and
North Dental
so it's a we end up with this balancing
process does the addition of these five
dwellings which will not be available
affordable really to many local people
at all uh does providing those there
with the additional transport that we
generated and it's not just the vehicles
from the five dwellings it's the other
vehicles that now travel about there's
lots of online delivery vehicles running
about traffic in the area of parkham
is along very narrow roads and I was
amazed when I saw the lane that this is
going to be allowed to access onto I
know it's not far from The Junction but
I mean
I I just can't support this because I'm
not happy about the sewage trains from
here being available and satisfactory
and I also think we should have done a
proper traffic assessment of the area
they're adding more traffic into the
area is what's already out it should
have been assessed if it hasn't been
shot
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and get comfortable
then ppf to State all developments that
will generate significant amounts one of
the significant amounts of movement
should be required to provide a travel
plan and then the application should be
supported by a transport statement or
transport assessment
so that they're like the likely impacts
of The Proposal can be assessed and we
haven't got that we've just got a
statement from highways saying that it
might be inconvenient to people which I
think when I read that word inconvenient
another issue just taking it through on
Monday evening at full Council Torrid
should approved the part of the
neighborhood plan and I wonder how that
would affect this application
it wouldn't affect the United States
that that meeting that established the
name of the parking neighborhood is just
the initial start of it so we can't
consider any there's no no implication
at all for this application chair
right unless anybody I'm pleasing
everybody is contribution
um
so it was proposed back cancer not
accepted by cancer brand to approve the
application would you take the vote
please thank you Chad
uh cancel the bank too okay councilor
Brown councilor Christie against
councilor craigie against attachment
against cancer lock four councilor wise
men or councilor Pennington yes
that's three four and five against chair
Motionless
so can I just ask then on what reasons
you are going to stay for turning it
down
lack of a transport assessment is one
lack of information on the sewage
treatment plant being
I've been able to accept this amount of
sewage well whether really the question
is whether any improvements have been
made enough
and I did see
one of our policies in here
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
recommendation for approval
um so
the lack of a transport assessment we
have to be mindful that the highway
Authority is raising their objection so
there would be risks in my view and it's
going to advise you on this in a highway
reason for refusal
um similarly lack of detail on on the
sewage treatment plant there is a
statutory obligation on Southwest water
to provide drainage and which sits under
separate legislation so again I would
have concerns that we are stepping into
an area that would put the cancer at
risk as well notwithstanding the fact I
do acknowledge that this is a
significant issue for methods and the
frustrations around the lack of
information and detail on on the
capacity of that system and in terms of
policy st07 that the race conflict with
that policy as recognized in the officer
report and the policies of the plan are
still the starting point
um so there is an element of harm
associated with that conflict with
policy however as set out in the
officers report we have policy St 21
which is engaged at the moment and part
two of that policy does allow for sites
to come forward outside the development
boundary so that the weight to that time
that of that conflict with sto7 is
reduced for that reason
um similarly there is an element of
conflict with with policy power the
spatial strategy for parkham as well
um however members must be mindful that
that's housing figure within that policy
is a minimum
um so
ultimately you're being asked to
consider something under the tilt of
balance and the the reason for refusal
obviously would need to articulate these
concerns but also
um make it a very clear recommendation
that this the harm Associates of these
outweighs the benefits of the product
weddings and I've heard a lot about
cumulative impacts and there's different
ways of looking at that so in terms of
on utilities and infrastructure we don't
have any technical objections on
infrastructure with a sewage or highways
um and just sort of cumulative harm
the the officers report it's very clear
that there was there is a significant
landscape part albeit recognizing this
is outside of the development boundary
so they're inevitably will be an element
of harm associated with the loss of what
is currently a green field
um so I hope that's helpful in just
trying to sort of sort of focus and we
will need sort of policies to back up
the different elements where the
conflict is as well thank you Helen well
let's see on seven for sure and also
without looking at it now sg21 I think
it is broadly agrees with sd21 but not
completely agreement
what is the impact is it the only
development in the area
principally on the highways and the
immunity of all the residents in parking
I'm just can't keep adding and adding
and adding properties in a village like
Park and without having detrimental
impact on the residence and that really
is the main concern for me along with
lack of informational weather treatment
plan to park and consult with everyone
that that's a memory councilor Christie
could I just ask that we do stress the
sewage aspect most of all because
um you know my motion to the council
it's meant to be answered in 20 days
they said 20 working days they've
already had 15 I don't know if we've had
an employer but this whole thing about
the capacity we've just seen the recent
series still in Cornwall which is
horrifying
um if that happened up here
what would happen to our tourism
industry but I think we really need to
stressful because this keeps coming up
and I keep raising it and yeah we never
seem to get any answer for himself with
water they since they've been privatized
they've been a law unto themselves it
seems and I think we actually need to
really get this thrashed out and it also
because we're talking about a local
player which is one between us and North
Devon I've talked to North Devon
councils who have similar problems to
this in their Villages and their towns
and we really do need to get to the
bottomless because we're all aware I
think Southwest water has been slated
what is it the last 10 years they're in
the bottom two or something
their performance and it really is
having an impact around this area
thank you councilor Christian Pop cst21
managing the delivery of housing goes on
brackets to to talk about
in a location of the scale and nature
commensurate to the deficit in required
housing well these five may come forward
they might not because I think canceled
all and I read it in the report there
are two landowners involved here and if
they don't agree it could be it would be
it wouldn't come forward very closely
this in any event I don't know as far as
Parkin's concerned there's any deficit
in housing at all
so this is all part of the balancing
process
[Music]
and also in sd21 it mentions being
brought broadly is either use these
wires that you can take this way or that
way broadly consistent with not
prejudicial to and contribution to work
contributing towards the positive
achievement of the plans overall spatial
vision and strategy for Northern Devon
along with the relevant settlement
Division and development strategy rule
as I said right at the start
Parkin's strategy for parking business a
minimum 15. it didn't talk about the
minimum 100 which we're looking towards
there
um
so how do you think it conflicts
actually with what's beneficial for this
that's what it's about and we have to
find the policies that support it that
is the beneficial for the people
the benefit benefits of this benefit if
it isn't uh
and it does speak about
local needs and what's needed and to
support the local community and I don't
believe there's a local need for these
at all nobody's ever spoken about not
looking these dwellings but but there's
a local need for these five
in this open Countryside location as I
said we don't if
I'm having an unsupplying situation we
wouldn't entertain this site being it
where it is and it isn't it's always
difficult it's balancing
but I do think we've made the right
decision and if the applicant which is
there right want to take it to appeal
well
but we've made it and I think the very
valid reason
so another vote will obviously need to
be taken with that information to refuse
and so the policies Council level you've
mentioned is the conflict with policy
st07 yeah
um rural spatial strategy and elements
of st21 and part two and on the mpbf
which speaks about
all right
traffic assessment
needed to be a transport statement but
it doesn't need a proper transport
assistance for the area and it's only
five dwellings but and it's not just the
10 cars if if you've got two two
vehicles or five guys if you're it's the
rest of the transport that gets
generated with these developments it's
not just the site itself I mean you can
have delivery vehicles coming day day in
and day out I mean areas
okay
you know multiple ones so I do think we
should be a proper assessment and just
to say it might be inconvenient but it's
an awful thing just to put in
so that would be policy dnsi of the
local plan and the mppf actually the
para 111 is is irrelevant and that's
very clear that development should only
be presented or refused on Highway
grounds there would be an unacceptable
impact of Highway Safety or the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
will be severe that's a very high bar
inconvenient I would say
isn't severe that you could still
um as you suggest Council leather
um
indicate that there's insufficient level
of information
on highways and and to sewage if that's
what the recommendations I mean and it
is all the development the vehicles
whilst this development was being done
traveling up these narrow layers I know
you know people often raise this but if
you're building you've got to have
delivery vehicles coming in but the
roads in the area really have never been
improved I think so I can't remember
anything it seemed any improved in the
welcome area so right well I'll propose
that it's refused now
and if somebody
to yourself
well I proposed I'm comfortable in this
sentence for the reasons we just
discovered that it's true he does
clarify those reasons
yes so conflicts with policy sts7 which
is the the rural special strategy
um policy St 21 so much for two elements
of
um policy dma5 in regards to highways I
would suggest in terms of the drainage
we would have sto3 but also dmo4 which
is a design policy as well
um
you can make reference to the mppx as
well
um although I did maintain the mental
impact isn't severe and if it's more a
case of lack of information then you
could rely on policy DNA so it's then
making clear that those conflicts that
way
the benefits as part of any and contrary
to the park and spatial strategy yes par
yeah
because seeing that does say support for
appropriate additional employment to
address local needs there's no aspect of
supporting employment with this at all
or any loved ones right there's been
proposed accepted by a cancer law
for those reasons can we check the vote
please sir thank you Joe councilor by
turn forward
councilor Brown again
councilor Christie for
cancer craigie or cancer leather for
cancer a lot against councilor wise men
councilor Pennington four
that's five four refused of chair and
three against
thank you Sandra foreign
[Music]
building to provide dwelling as part of
the existing holiday accommodation at
Coastal cabins
so we've got the application site
outlined in red Romania area land
ownership in blue and the application
site includes the existing amenity
building and there's the smaller the
rectangles in the red line and the
larger one being a tennis court
and then the associated land around it
there's existing access
to the north of the amenity building
from the public Highway and public
Highway runs to the east of the site
the block plan shows with existing trees
and hedging to the north of the access
and also indicates the proposal for two
parking spaces immediately adjacent
dwelling
uh just an error photograph to show
um the nearest neighboring dwelling more
than anything else
um so the Dutch house is the one to the
north and you can see a very roughly put
the red line in there as to the
application site and you can see the uh
glamping pods associated with Coastal
cabins that are set adjacent to it on
the pond
so we've got existing plans and
elevations so the building was
constructed as a communal cooking and
sort of living space along some storage
areas associated with the glamping site
no alterations are proposed to the
external elevations as part of the
development with the exception of the
back box being added to these elevation
but you can see from the floor plan
there and we gain a three-bedroom
dwelling there with the associated
Living Kitchen facilities
we have some photographs
um proposed that shows the existing
building and from the southwest and from
the south and you can just see the
fencing for the tennis court
on the right hand side of the bottom
picture there
is from the north and along the existing
access
the existing building
I'll just put in a picture just to show
you the adjacent Highway and the
existing access point that's in place
so if we run through the client
considerations and the principal
um The Proposal is considered to meet
the test set out policy dm-27 for the
conversion of existing buildings
to the principle must be supported
um it is located within the AUB and
within the undervoked coast suppose the
st09 and it's been assessment it's not
concerned to result in any harms of the
undeveloped Coast as the building's
already there
policy st07 for the reusement existing
building so the principal is considered
to be supported
uh the impacts on design and character
we've got no external alterations so no
adverse impact is considered to result
in the surrounding amb
in terms of residential amenities it's
obviously set at some distance to the
nearest neighboring dwelling to the
north of the thatched house and we're
being keeping the character of the
adjacent holiday use
and the Environmental Protection Officer
is recommended at any kind of
Destruction working hours condition
which is included in your recommendation
and and also really included a condition
restricting the use to being associated
with the adjacent holiday business and
to ensure that there's no potential harm
to Future occupiers from the adjacent
holiday business and that's conditioned
by the recommendation in front of you
in terms of access and parking and
there's an existing access and it's not
considered there'll be any significant
change in terms of vehicle movements
associated with the change of use
to comply with policy dma5 and dmo6
the ecology and biodiversity no adverse
impacts would result in place change
abuse and protected species or their
habitats
and the proposed enhancements would
include the addition of black boxes and
a sparrow Terrace as well and the
recommendations for approving thank you
Laura
we've got three contributors to this
education
our first one Speaking against his
grandmother and to the public if you'd
like to come up to the microphone
speaking to the end of that one please
and yeah once she said we've got three
minutes to adjust here representing the
parish council oh hi you're encourage
Council yeah
right good morning committee um
there is a history to this site some of
you will recall when the application
originally came to committee back in
2012 for 10 years on an immunity block
which was granted mission
there were conditions to the application
one of which to begin the build within
three years
condition nine stated that if the site
was no longer used with the sighting of
Yurts then the site be reinstated in its
entirety to its original state
another condition 10
stated that the premises shall be used
for Holiday accommodation only and for
no other purposes
I would argue this application for
residential accommodation reaches the
original Panic condition 10 which was
applied to the whole site
there was an amendment of subsequently
to the urkes and that they were
converted to wooden structures with
canvas roofs
that was granted
they know are wooden cabins with wooden
felt clad roofs
this would cause me to argue these are
no cabins not Europe's but as such could
also be construed as being a breach of
planning condition nine
as there have been no as there has been
no amendment to change the roof
materials
these cabins now apparently have full
facilities within each of them which has
never been granted or applied for
then there was another amendment in 2020
the changes to the amenity shed
which was granted permission in 2012.
but had in fact not been built
there was then subsequently constructed
and then after Parish councilor pointed
out and are concerned about
there's been a very small period of time
elapsed between the bill and now
requested change of use and a new
application for a residential dwelling
foreign
capacity for the sewage is as has been
said for 10 yards
and there are 10 cabins
and a dwelling which can accommodate at
least four people is also added it's not
Rocky science to work out the current
system would in fact as the parish
councilor raise concerns about in DP
oversubscribed
I would sum up my station as a
supervisory dwelling is already
available overlooking the site that
being the thatched house
which is already in the ownership of the
applicant an action and that actually
this current application is a breach of
the original planning condition 10.
as such in my view there is no proven
need for this new dwelling neither
hasn't been proven that the immunity
block is in fact no longer needed
it could be morphed into any range of
uses which could add facilities to this
site in other ways
I would suggest this is a planning
loophole to enable the applicant to
maximize Financial potential by creating
a residential sale as well as a business
sale
I would remind them maybe that this site
is within the aom B
less you
know
I'm our next speaker I'll just change
that to Paris that we've heard
our next speaker is Melissa Sheldon in
support of the application
member of the public
once you set these three minutes as well
to progress
[Music]
when we speak today
um my name is Melissa sorry could you
speak into the mic I'm sorry do not hear
it no you have to speak around
you have to be run into them
[Music]
um so yeah good morning thank you for
hearing me speak today my name is
Melissa Sheldon
um I run Coastal cabins glamping in
Heartland with my parents
um Janet and John Cockrell
we have successfully created and run
this business together for eight years
now
prior to this my parents also ran
another business in Heartland for over
30 years so we've been there for quite
some time they're now in their mid 70s
and quite deservedly would now like to
retire it's been a really tough couple
of years
um but then sorry
um because of covid
um
I've been involved in marketing and
financial perspects of running Coastal
cabins since its Inception and with my
parents retirement
I will now need to fully manage the site
I can only live 30 miles away in
braunton with my two young children and
my husband who also runs his business in
children
we pride ourselves in our many
outstanding reviews all of which talk of
our exceptional customer service
it is imperative that we are able to
respond in a timely manner to the needs
and demands of our clients whether
giving advice or dealing with any issues
which can and do arise
this attention to detail is what keeps
our visitors returning to our sites each
year our business has not only given a
large number of people employment but we
also heavily promote the local
restaurants pubs and tourist attractions
in our local area
maintaining this level of service from
such a distance or if there will be
almost impossible especially when I when
also looking after two young children
it's therefore necessary for me and my
family to have accommodation during
these Peak periods on site this proposed
change of use will enable me to continue
running the business that I love
and be on hand to welcome guests and
provide a level of five-star commitment
that we provide our pride ourselves in
I would ask once you support me in this
application in order that I continue to
run this business to help provide for my
family and also continue to bring much
needed quality tourism into the area
thank you thank you
thank you
our final speaker on this is Graham
Townsend who's the agent for the
application
the module settlement is sometimes then
you've got three minutes as well to
adjust thank you
thank you chair members
um I'm here as has been said as agent
for the application uh Melissa has
advised uh what the granting of this
application will mean both for her her
family and the business I would like to
address the planning and policy issues
involved your officers of recommended
approval of the application and I
commend their recommendation
brief comment on the report there is
reference to the thatched house being 20
meters north of the site this is
actually about 65 meters north of the
North Boundary and some 80 meters from
the building that's the subject of this
application so there's a slight error
correct in there
um Again by way of clarification of the
facts there are 10 not 11 of hospitals
been referred to as and situations
cabins each is one bedroom in relation
to the drainage provision which has been
questioned 10 bedrooms of the cabins and
the proposed two or three bedrooms of
this proposed dwelling are adequately
catered For by the existing drainage
system this has been confirmed and
checked by using the government's water
flow calculator
and this system is large enough to take
the capacity of the 10 cabins and this
proposed dwelling so as the impact of
works are concerned these will be
internal only apart from putting up the
button and bird boxes uh the owners are
not going to upset their guests so uh
hourly restrictions especially out of
season
um we would have thought were not
required but uh if if members feel that
construction activity should be limited
then it's it's sort of a huge issue
the main policy of this application
um needs to comply with is dm-27 of the
approved local plan the building was
originally to be an immunity block for
years subsequent switch to cabins has
rendered that effectively redundant
common cooking showering and toilet
facilities are no longer post covered
feature that people seem to desire
presence of an on-site manager which
this application will facilitate is very
much what part of what makes this
business successful
the other requirements of dm-27 are met
as the officer report concludes the
requirement of section 38 6 of the 2004
planning and compulsory Purchase Act is
that applications are determined in
accordance with the provisions of the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise I
respectfully suggest that none of the
objections that have been raised to this
application can be substantiated as
representing material planning
considerations to justify refusal of the
application therefore I would urge
members to support the officer
recommendation and approve the
application thank you and she turns out
well that's the last last of our
contributors
[Music]
who would like to start the discussion
on this I do know that
it's just a as an aside that
we had an application last time I think
in concordbury Road it's overlooked or
was overlooked from the aom to the aonb
put quite a lengthy
a statement in regarding that I noticed
that this is actually within the airwnb
and the Heritage course have been a word
from nothing no contribution to them at
all who would like to start the actual
character Christie yeah um yeah I read
through this and it seems there seems
all sorts of oddities about this
application I have to ask myself firstly
do 10 glamping pods require a
supervisory Drilling is a campsite all
right so these have become slightly more
permanent but I do wonder you know what
is the supervisor who's planning they
mean and then I heard that
the applicant wants to come they need to
travel quite a distance
and I thought well the husband lives in
braunton I'm not sure where they live in
Broad tonight so
um
the husband is now going to have to
travel from Heartland back to Broughton
to run his business it's I couldn't
quite get my head around that and the
other thing is on page 41
uh the fourth parallel four paragraph
that will fifth paragraph down of course
that was a free apps being made
um
and it says uh oh sorry it's one sorry
one two three four five six seven
paragraph down sorry
what is frequently referred to as a
welcome Monster by the owners the
current site owners and manager live
close to the site and that's out but
they've sold the other tourism business
I own in the vicinity and I'll soon to
move
well if they're soon to move why can't
the person move into their house
and use that as a supermarket trick
diving
um they seem to be wanting two
supervisory Darlings whereas one's going
to be empty fairly soon I can't quite
get my head around all this it's a
contradictory
I'm not saying what I think about the
application I'm just wondering what's
going on with some clarity be helpful on
that Council Christy so you'll see from
um which page set page 39 of your agenda
report list the policy context for for
this application and each of the Agenda
Report does now
applications to supervisory dwellings
would be considered against policy dm-28
um
agricultural workers dwellings or
supervisory Darlings because we're all
businesses you'll see that policy 28
isn't isn't included on the list and
that's that's because this is primarily
being considered under dm-27 which is
conversion of the Redundant building
um so that's the the prime primary
policy that should be considered as a
test associated with dm-27 one of which
is whether it is redundant or disused
now the the condition tying it to the
the operation at the campus way is
purely to just satisfy the objection on
the amenity grounds raised by the
Environmental Protection Officer so I
would agree this is a slightly unusual
situation that your Prime policy is
supposed CDM 27 it's not being put
forward under a functional need for a
supervisory dwelling helps policy Jam
2018 of the future I hope that helps
thank you sorry can you go back to the
point about
the current managers are soon to move so
that bill detached houses apparently
going to be empty soon so why do they
need unsupervisor employee and this is
what I can't understand
oh
yeah the thing is you can't
it's the mother and father now and the
owners they're returning and selling up
um this is Helen said a redundant
deadline
and we can argue it soon became redempt
but they've changed the actual
instead of your accident you've got
these little cabins with canvas roofs
that now have their own
washroom and showering sorry that's a
that's my question
um there are applying for a supervisory
dwelling
because apparently they need one well
that's the reason that they want to
change it from its current use to that
right yes I understand that but also the
current supervisory drilling where the
current managers live is going to become
empty soon so why do they need another
supervisor who darling when the first
one is becoming empty
if I just came in again so if you look
on page
um 36 which which is both the front
cover sheet that sets out the the actual
proposal and you'll see the description
of development is change abusive
redundant amenity building to dwelling
there's no there's there's no reference
to it being a supervisory dwelling so
this is this is not a proposal brought
forward on the basis of it being a
supervisory dwelling and there being a
need for such notwithstanding the the
circumstances that are set out in here
and as
I think you are technically right but we
heard from themselves I'm sorry
um yes so Council Christie I I
absolutely understand your point um the
the desire for clarification but it is
policy dn27 you're considering the fact
that there is a condition tying it to
the camping ground is is Justified on a
man's ground
can you Helen while you've got the mate
could you just answer
the issues is raised by the parish
council but if this was no longer needed
as an amenity building it had to be
demolished and the site reinstated is
that reference to a condition Yes again
Laura might be best place to answer on
on the planning planning history if I
could if I could hand over to Laura on
that
okay so the previous
um permission so it's 2012
um and the description of development
was for 10 years including a facilities
block department and access and I think
there was reference made to
Edition nine if I can read that out for
you in the event that the site is no
longer in use for the sighting of the
year it's within 12 months following the
cessation of the use any bases drainage
pipes and connecting parts shall be
removed from the site and the site
restored to its previous state in
accordance with the scheme that should
have been submitted to and approved in
writing with the LPA
and that was in the interest of the
visual amenity in the area
obviously the business is still ongoing
is the only thing I would say in
response to that and there was a
reference also to condition 10
which was a condition we put on a lot of
holiday accommodation which
states that the premises shall be used
for Holiday accommodation only and for
no other purposes including any purpose
in class C3 of the schedule to the town
of country planning newscaster Georgia
1987 as amended or any other relevant
provision so it's a very standard one
the members in
so it doesn't specifically mention this
immunity block but if it's no longer
needed is that it's got to be
denomination no it's in reference to the
entire development in the business right
exactly thank you
black cancel the law
yeah well I um agree with Captain
Chris's Point
um on the family they might be moving I
mean and they run another business in
rules and I mean the family's personal
business and private numbers is
absolutely not a material planning
consideration I know I know exactly
where Canada cruise is coming from but
we can't consider that their private
lives
um to the condition on page 49.
there's a number five
could we not add the words and shall not
result on the over Market
I've been a lot happy with that have you
included not on the open market
or LED separately
so if condition five red the dwelling
here by the chair will be occupied only
by a person currently almost recently
involved in the management also the
vision of the adjoining holiday business
currently known as the coastal cabins
today their dependence widow or widower
and shall not be sold on the open market
I'd like those words inserted all that
separate things
I think that makes it more confusing I
don't know what the open market is
does anybody else know what the opening
Market is I would have thought that the
words
um
sold or left separately to the hatched
area which is the business
would that mean that the business that
if what's that mean you can't how I
don't understand that I think I think
these words are more clear sorry it
mentioned I mean yeah but I'm talking
about that you know if it is if it is
getting permission it is changing into
anything else that should not be sold on
the over Market separately
well it does say that as I read it it
should not be sold
or let separately from the area hatched
green which is a campsite
so it can't be sold seven yeah and I I
think reference to open market there is
potential Private Sales outside of the
open market which
um I yeah I think I think the wording
sold this is yeah I think it comes in
cancer yeah right I'll even withdraw
that one but it can't be sold separately
from the rest of the clumping so
country Craig thank you I just like to
say I think that we should be supporting
rural businesses and they're
particularly important to us now they
sustain our shops they stay in our pulse
which we're always losing
um Club being so popular with you know
the young City people and they come out
living in a Filipino field they love it
but I do think there should be somebody
on site because there will be problems
and then I I just think we should be
looking at this as you know this is one
of our Royal businesses a lot of them
are failing we've got to support them
and you know that it's not going to
alter the appearance or anything so I
can't see any problem with it
thank you councilor Craig counselor
Pennington and then Council of Wiseman
yeah thank you chair just to go back to
condition five on paper
green area
I take it that's the area with the 10
years did it but it's not touch screen
on our picture on page 36 on the planet
yeah
okay which is on the site location plan
that's submitted as part of the
application okay thank you for that yeah
and I am an echo coach for a previous
point of view
um holiday business has changed an awful
lot since covered and communal
facilities are really being rejected
quite strongly and businesses need to be
able to change and adapt to situations
they're facing so I'm minded of balance
um to go with the office recommendation
here on that basis chair so it is having
a business to be able to change and
adapt to its situation and I can see why
the communion blockers has has not been
used actually when you balance it coach
Council Pennington councilor-wise so
Council craigie and Council Pennington
on what are the most important points I
think a great extensive I will um I'm
quite happy to propose that we are
drawing the application with the
um the conditions attached I'll second
that push him in that cancer
yeah because when I looked at it and
looked at the building
it's very unobtrusive and it's set in it
is there the building is there
um and I do agree with the comments made
by councilor Craig in councilor
Pennington actually that we should be
looking wherever we come to support our
rural tourism industry absolutely so
it's been moved to improve unless
anybody else wants a net comment moves
to approved by councilor Wiseman
seconded by councilor long did you take
the vote for yourself thank you
thanks to the Brown
cancer Christie for cancer craigie or
councilor leather or cancel a lot for
all councilor wise men or councilor
Pennington four
seven four and one upstairs
thank you Laura
our next application
application 7 C on pages 51
to 65 which is appropriate application
and James Jackson and plumbing
thank you thank you Jack
thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
this just shows the um well first of all
just a quick verbal update actually for
members
um since the drafting of the report
there has been won for the rejection
received from uh the occupier of an
existing dwelling just to the north west
of the site which is shown there as
broad gate Barton
um the issues raised are um potentially
overlooking to the frontage of their
property additional noise from future
occupies of the development and the
potential for runoff from the surface
water soaked way and the foul drainage
and package treatment plans
over development of the site and also
that the the dwelling would not be an
affordable home for local people
so this is the cyclocation location plan
the site as in red there it's within the
built-up area of cookery which qualifies
as a rural settlement within the local
plan due to the presence of the church
within the settlement and it's got
Residential Properties to the Northeast
and West and the public highway to the
South uh opposite the site is showing
them adjacent to that the blue Air the
blue line is a site that has excellent
planning permission for a single
dwelling
um we access currently is on that on the
southern boundary of the site that is to
be moved it will still be within the
southern boundary but within a more
central location
um and the public Highway as Islands
alone that serves a
collection of dwellings for seven or
eight different dwellings and then Beach
down to agricultural land
um outside of cookery
uh the drainage situation is slightly
unusual with this application to the to
the west of the side we have broad gate
Cottage
and the septic tank that serves that
property
has historically always been located
within the site within the red line
boundary and obviously then that that's
not within that owner's ownership if you
see my point
um it recently came to light that that
septic tank has been discharging
directly onto the site without the
Drainage Field
um and I understand that that was sort
of covered the Outlook was just covered
by a piece of corrugated iron
separately to planning legislation the
Environmental Protection Team is
certainly enforcement notice on the um
on the owner of that dwelling which
requires him to obviously mitigate that
issue and provide some um uh a more
acceptable drainage solution basically
so I think it's just important to
consider that in in the round it should
also be noted by members that regardless
of where the Planning Commission is
granted today or refused
um that that enforcement notice still
runs and is in place and the separate
environmental legislation so the owner
of that site to the West would still be
required to
um to correct that drainage situation
currently
uh next slide please
uh this is just an aerial image uh
you've got the bullet area on the left
uh with the site is marked by the red
star there and if it was just worth
mentioning as I was showing on the over
on the right hand side you've got the
tracking free Village Hall
um so the the Bradford Primary School
um has two primary classes within it and
um and the Village Hall has understood
sort of opposite a number of weekend
monthly events uh for the community and
so I think that's set out within your
office's report that that is quite
personal to the officer's recommendation
today in terms of that relationship
between the real form of cookery and the
the society rather Remote application of
the village hall and uh and the school
map
um companies approximately six
kilometers to the Northeast poles we
need and um next slide for it
okay this is just an indicative site
plan
um we'll see as I mentioned at the start
the application is an outline
application is almost reserved access so
this the location they are shown in
about dwelling in the Southeast corner
is an indicative location only that if
members were minded to go out playing
permission today that is not fixed in
that location it's really just to show
that that could be accommodated on the
site there up in the northeast corner we
have the Drainage Field which were to
serve two
um package treatment plants one to serve
the dwelling they proposed and one to
serve the dwelling to the west to
correct the existing trainers
as I mentioned earlier
um
population tests have been found to be
acceptable for the system queries from
our Environmental Protection Team the
Drainage Field is correctly sized and
located sufficient distance from site
boundaries and neighboring properties to
ensure compliance with the relevant
British standard
rather unusually there is a condition
recommended for this for the applicant
to provide an as-built plan of the power
drainage once installed the reasoning
behind that really is because there's
obviously a constrained site and and I
think there is a need in your office's
view to absent security that the actual
the file drainage can be
constructed as shown really
the other main constraint on the site is
within the northwest corner
um there's a TPO Cecil oak tree there
um with a A reproduction area a 15 meter
radius as well which is shown on on that
plan there so
obviously within that reproduction area
we can't have any development so that
acts as a constraint on the site there
so
um
just to note on the power Journey
proposals really
um and anything else Environmental
Protection related we do have Matthew
Miller Church who's one of the councils
uh Environmental Protection officers
here today so if members did have any
specific queries on in relation to those
matters their matters here to to assist
uh next slide please
uh this is just a few photographs top
left we have the TPO tree accessible Oak
top right we have broadgate Barton which
is the dwelling to the north west of the
site beyond the TPO tree
bottom left is a view across the site
um looking and south from the northern
boundary
bottom center is the existing access of
the southern boundary
the bottom right is the site from the
highway in the background there you can
also see the driveway to broadly
Broadmead Park which is the white white
pillar there that's the dwelling to the
media east of the site
assignment slopings
so top left broad get Cottage
which is the dwelling to the to the West
and the site is in the background there
that is the the dwelling that that has
the existing
um drainage issue
comp Center is looking East along public
Highway bottom left is looking West
along public Highway
bottom center is the village hall and
the bottom right is the private school
went inside this
so the material considerations in this
case are the principal observance
character and appearance residential
amenity biodiversity highways found in
Central Florida drainage
uh cookery is not ordinary a location
where um where open market residential
would be supported by officers but as
members aware that are aware the council
kind of currently demonstrates a
five-year supply of housing land
uh and therefore there is necessary to
understand
and as members aware that that states
that Planning Commission should be
granted unless the adverse impacts
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
and so I set out within the office of
committee report it is considered
pertinent in this instance that the uh
The Village Hall and the school are
located within close proximity but
outside of the settlement it's clear
that they are going to need to draw
um on persons from the rural sort of
area within Hinterland and for that
reason it is considered that the priest
is acceptable location for modestly
scaled residential development at this
time and that's also obviously on the
basis that the cancer panel currently
demonstrating five minutes of time
um and so taking account of that it is
uh is recommended that the Planning
Commission should be granted subject to
the conditions
set out on page 61 to 64 of your agenda
if there's any questions I'd be happy to
try and help thank you chat thank you
James I'll ask you to vacate for a
minute while the public speakers come in
and then if you come back again to
answer any questions thank you
write our first contributor to this is
Fred Scott
speaking against and then who's the
member of the public
as you continue
okay
thank you and once you settle Mr Scott
you've got
three minutes to address the community
thank you very much
good morning thanks for listening to me
my name is Fred Scott
Cottage and I did this since 2004 when
we purchased it off the current
applicants
um
I am a retired senior building Clark of
works for the Department of planning and
Architectural London borough and a
building contractor
um we have and for the existing trainers
field and septic tank
now if you look at the left-hand side of
the revised plan issued on 20th of the
June July sorry September you will see
the sector pack is there and above it it
says that this will be decommissioned
and filled in concrete I couldn't assure
you that is not going to happen
absolutely 100
also if you follow the track that left
hand side down you'll see a treatment
plan which they say is going to be
connected to a
drainage that certainly will not happen
and the reason that is we would like the
treatment plan but the owners Mrs pepiat
who lives in Chippenham and Mr Mrs
larkwood new center want to own it and
we would be responsible that there was
an accident if somebody got hurt and
somebody got electrocuted we would be in
real trouble
we've took legal advice from Tucson and
they said don't go down this road
um now going on to the septic tank we
have tried constantly to get
into since last November when this was
discovered we had no idea this was
happening
we immediately contacted Mr Mark Hampton
Building Patrol came to side and we also
had a weird thing so I can meetings for
Mr Mark beer but Environmental Services
I must say it's been very helpful
um
the septic tank is due to have a minor
adaptment on the 21st of this month a
couple of weeks time which will bring it
up to bs62 times 7 which is a
requirement so there is no need
whatsoever to take the septic tank away
the Drainage Field is going to be put in
they've got two treatment plants is
because of the septic tank remains
it will not
boost the capability of the percolation
test and the big piece that have been
you know so weak that they've just
passed but they're weak so they need to
set the treatment plants to to do this
when I'm shop in things I found was
working out to take the age of putting
the application but it was asked if
there was any contamination people know
so the Africa could snow because we've
had a meeting in 20th of June
of environment Services who completely
saw the site so we ask you to wind up
now please Mr Scott okay now
um
we sorry
um
and we've been working with him to
resolve the matter but the other quick
thing is the road I cannot walk up the
road because it's in such a state that
since 2014 highways that refused to do
anything to the Lane and at the top of
the lane it's got a notice saying
unsuitable for Motor Vehicles I can't
even walk up the lane and if your
vehicles doesn't mean men and whatever
they were first down the road and come
out thank you Mr Scott I've got to say
okay thank you very much
right our next speaker against the
application is Anthony whitebeast
there's an email to be read out by the
planning manager
unfortunately due to work pressures I am
unable to be with you in person but I'm
grateful for our objection comments to
be presented in my absence
as we are aware there is a substandard
septic tank overflowing on this site our
argument in respect to this is a simple
one and relates to Public Health we feel
that without delay a Drainage Field
should be installed in an Optimum
position centrally located within the
site and as far away from existing
properties as possible at the moment
overflowing effluent is calling on the
site and has been seeking onto our
boundaries this planning application
appears to be delaying the required
improvements as multiple treatment
plants are considered on a site that has
no power and for a development that may
never happen there appears to be a lack
of agreement between the owners of the
land wishing to develop the plot and the
users of receptive account we are
concerned that permitting the
developments will prolong the time taken
to find an agreeable solution to
perceptic tank issue an immediate
solution needs to be found taking into
account the fact there is no power
supply
we feel that consideration should be
given to installing a Drainage Field to
the existing tank to soak away centrally
within the plot without delay the help
of our family and neighbors have been
put at risk for long enough please could
we sought out the current stinking
effluent at ground surface burst and
then decide on the planning application
at a later date
the proposed Drainage Field is squeezed
between our boundary and the Rope the
route protection zone of the better in
oak tree the plans show The Journey tool
to be seven meters up slope of our home
this again is not the optimal position
on the plot due to the close proximity
to our house as I understand building
regulations are through a 15 meter
separation from a property that clearly
is a good reason why this extra
clearance is required we object to the
proposal with the close proximity of the
Drainage Field puts us at greater risk
of discharge onto our property due to
the ever-increasing weather extremes
that are occurring due to global warming
the veteran oak on the site has a
massive stem and a 15 meter route
projection Zone 15 meters is the maximum
protection Zone that can be used no
matter how ground the tree the Woodland
draft considers that route protection
zones should be larger and the
calculations should use a factor of 15
times the stem diameter this makes sense
especially when you consider how dry
this summer has been let me stress the
trees have been under I therefore object
as the experts at Woodland trash to
recommend a calculation that would
result in a much larger reproduction
Zone and this appeared to indicate that
the current proposal could harm the root
system and ultimately retrieves Health
The Proposal therefore would result in a
tiny increase to housing stock with a
disproportionate negative impact on the
veteranics of David thank you for your
consideration
[Music]
thank you heather
a final contributor to this speaking in
favor of it is Walter wonnacott who's
the agent for the same and once you're a
settled Mr Monica you've got three
minutes to address the committee
foreign
[Music]
provides support for the new housing and
to meet local needs in such settlements
as a result of the lack of a five-year
housing land supplies considered the
local plan requirement for local needs
housing is no longer a determinative
factor the report outlines a number of
factors to support the principal
development including the proximity of
brand for Primary School Bradford
Bradford and Capri Village Hall Each of
which are dependent on surrounding
villages to ensure their viability and
vitality I could agree it's one such
surrounding Village
the mppf at paragraph Center 9 supports
new housing where development in one
Village May Support Services in Village
nearby
planning permissions granted for a
dwelling to the immediate Southwest of
the site in December 2020 on the other
side of the road the principle for a
dwelling here is an entirely
uncontroversial
the 21st of October this year councilor
Apple confirmed to me via email that he
had suggested to the adjoining
landowners that he should cancel this
call and notice as all three
conservative raised have been addressed
before although Council heple agreed to
keep calling in place for the neighbor's
request it's quite clear he does not
himself challenge Mr Jackson's
recommendations any further
the site has two unusual features as
raised by bonus Jackson there's a TBO
and an oak tree to the Northwest and the
site is required under d as referenced
by Mr Scott however this is the quote
the use of the existing septic tank or
drainage system including the Overflow
Range Five serving the same or such
other system as made from time to time
replace the same for the disposal of
soil and effluent water from the
adjoining property to the West as may
replace the same
although this is not modification
napkins commissioned the drainage system
designed to take account of these two
features they are unusual and the time
of council hepbald's calling the final
design had not yet been agreed or
published but it's since been accepted
by not one but two in prime minister
Health officer smart beard and Matthew
Miller jackets behind me
Bishop Jackson's report also confirms
the eho advice that the failure of the
existing Drainage Field presents no
material planning contamination issue in
a standard contamination condition may
be applied the proposal would provide
for a significant improvement over the
current situation via packaged treatment
plans which much better deal with raw
sewage instead of a septic tank on site
is preferred by the neighbor
the design was produced in collaboration
with another culturalist confirming the
root protection Zone will be preserved
to the National Standard which is 15
meters
and finally this is a very worst it's a
very lightly traffic time right through
a website location is with an existing
access to the plot already and good
visibility in both directions the
highways officer raises no concerns over
access and in reference to the company
made earlier the science is not suitable
for for vehicles it's firm up the road
um to the other end of the road not down
this part there's no evidence at all
before the committee to come to a view
other than that of its own expert
officials on planning drainage
contamination or on access I invite
members to support the application
accordingly I'd be happy to answer any
questions
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um when I saw this I looked at the
site and I thought oh it's an infield
site marvelous is a fan of a village you
know it doesn't seem any problems about
being in the open Countryside or
anything like that
um all this stuff about the sewage
is that part of the planning process for
this because it seems to be almost a
civil matter to me I'm not quite certain
you know what weight we should give to
it and I'll come back to that but
um I do sympathize with a gentleman who
talks about the road I'm on Google Earth
at the moment the road
looks like a World War One Battlefield
it's just horrendous but I realize
that's not part of the thing but there
is one thing on Google Earth you can see
very clearly there's an overhead wire
and right across where they want to put
the house which serves the houses both
sides I'm not sure what it is
but I can't quite see how they're going
to recite that very easily can you tell
me about that
yeah thank you guys so and so I think
first of all in terms of the foul
drainage there it is a planning matter
in terms of
um in terms of the proposed way and
obviously needs to provide
um satisfactory arrangements for the
treatment and management of foul
drainage so that's one issue it does
cross over into environmental
legislation as well because obviously
we've got the enforcement notice that
relates to exists of drainage that
serves Mr Scott's property and there are
also some civil matters in there as well
because I mean obviously Mr Scott about
the legal easements Etc they're all
civil matters
um and and whether or not
um in terms of that liability from the
drainage proposal they're all simple
answers really so from the climate
perspective there's obviously a
requirement for this dwelling to to
provide acceptable drainage um the
environment Protection Officer is
comfortable that that has been provided
and so that's that's the sort of extent
of it really implying terms
the road condition I would accept is not
is not great it's traditionally the work
there's there's
um sort of some potholes down there as
well the the reference to the they've
been suitable for
um Motor Vehicles it does really relate
to further down and Zane I don't think
members are aware that sort of goes into
agricultural land we've had issues down
there before it is dwellings down there
or using those sites down there for
various
um various activities which has caused
problems but I think from as was
mentioned on one of the earlier
applications really in terms of the mpps
requirement in terms of wood would
um the impact on Highway
um on the highway that would be severe
or would it acceptably affect highway
safety then from your officer point of
view there's obviously this road serves
kind of seven or eight dwellings already
and it's a question of would the
addition of one single dwelling actually
take that balance to be a severe impact
and and from your officer's point of
view and it wouldn't really and so it
would be would be acceptable
um Nativity overhead wired up again to
support within planning that would be a
matter for the applicants to resolve
we've got Cherry Utilities company that
that falls with him really and I'd love
to make um appropriate uh
um appropriate actions in that regard
thank you on that basis then I'll
propose we accept it thank you guys for
Christy
occasionally yeah I've just got one
assigned really
um in the plan in history
um on page 52
there's a review for all terrorist
weddings is that on exactly the same
size plot as what we're discussing there
um so it it is yeah I actually no sorry
it's on the opposite plot on the green
on the um can we go back to the end
um sorry the site location plan
so
so where the blue line is there and then
we have the um that green space there
that's that's a site with one uh
permission for one exercise do I think
at the moment and so that that's the
site that relates to those
um previous recusals all right
I mean go and touch it on
um the remoteness of it I mean I don't
know how many members of the plans
committee were on the plans committee
when we did accept our plans committee
meeting at corporate Village Hall when
we used to go around various places
um it is back to the vicinity the school
and the village hall and I will second
count as a Christie's recommendation it
is approved
thank you Council lock
anybody else want to make comment
foreign
training system
I can't see any issue with one dwelling
going on that side the ones that were
refused were the two was at two dwellers
and four drones
special measure trees but it's been
proposed by councilor Christie certainly
by cancer a lot that this is granted
could you take the book pretty soon
thank you chair thanks for the mountains
councilor Brown for cancer Christie or
councilor craigie or pencil leather yeah
councilor Pennington or the unanimous
chair thank you so much
[Music]
we move on then too
our final application which is seven
days
one page is 66 to 74 of the agenda
Council Christianity
James is taking this one as well
thank you chat yes me again I'm afraid
um this is application one zero eight
one slash zero eight six three slash
twenty times twenty twenty twenty two
slash La uh the um proposal is the
formation of a construction access and
it's um land uh agree Graphics there
stated uh tracking away with the
business park is and call to committee
as the application is made by Torres
District Council and no further than
that place for this one
so here we have the site location plan
the site is edged in red it includes the
new access
um the visibility displays and the
construction road extended into part of
what is an existing agricultural field
the construction access would serve the
environment Center which is a planned
facility for the processing of household
recycling materials and food waste
should be noted by members that the
environment Center does not have
planning permission at this time yeah
the rationale really for this for this
application is to Future proof the
construction period if the environment
Center does get planning permission in
the future
um it would ensure that the council is
not reliant on third-party land to
construct the environment Center and
bring that forward
um currently as part of an agricultural
field as I said comprising semi-improved
grasslands
uh in terms of existing dwellings
there's one single dwelling which is
known as Bayview and is um located
approximately 100 meters uh to the west
of the site
there's an existing field gate in the
corner of the field
um other notable sort of features within
the area the Evans transport site is
located within close proximity to the
northwest
and the east of the water urban area
further to the northwest
um and obviously the gamuton road public
highway to the to the South as well
next slide please
um so just a couple of aerial images the
one on the left shows a close-up of the
site the red star is marked um where the
uh the location of the proposed access
and there you can see the the dwelling
in the cartilage of the dwelling known
as Bayview over to the west and then on
the right hand side is just um a
slightly wider angle of that you can see
the site marked with the star and then
its relationship to the Evans transport
site and also the built area of
um over to the northwest of of um
Biddeford uh it's probably worth just
noting as well along that southern sort
of edge of Biddeford of Easter water
really is all allocated for me to use
development for approximately 600 houses
and a new store and that's all I look at
it and uh um policy bid 04.
let's disciples
so headed to
um those site plans
which says on the left the new access
there the construction road going into
the field
um and on either side of the access road
and to 450 millimeter infiltration
trenches to deal with surface water uh
then the image on the right shows the
site in the context of the existing
dwelling known as Bayview over to the
west and also just shows an outline of
the broad location
um anticipated for the future
applications of the environment Center
and there's noted earlier that doesn't
have planning permission at this time
uh next slide please
this is just the existing and proposed
sections all these really show is that
there's no significant change to
existing ground levels on the site as a
result of The Proposal the next slide
please
and then here we have some photographs
top left there's a public Highway
accident proposed access looking West
you can see the um the dwelling known as
Bayview in the distance there uh top
right is the public Highway looking East
bottom left is um looking North from the
top of the field down across the field
um bottom center is looking South that's
the section of the Hedgerow to be
removed there and then bottom right is
just a more distant View and back
towards that hedger
looks like this
a couple more photographs left is the
Evans transport site which is to the
northwest of the site and then right is
the Evans site in the context of that
field and again you can see that
dwelling known as behavior in the
background there
all right next slide please
so the two considerations in this case
are the principle of development
character and clearance residential
amenity biodiversity highways surface
water drainage and a section on other
matters as well then your officers
report
um I think in the main consideration
obviously for members is that they are
considering the the access itself and
the effects that really associate with
that access really so obviously there
just needs to be a distinction there
between the effects that would be
associated with the actual environment
sector which will obviously go forward
for another application at some time but
we'll also need to compensate commission
members at that time will need to
consider the effects associated with
that development
um and so for the reason to set out in
your reporters your offices view the
proposal just called with the provisions
of the development plan as a whole and
uh example recommended that Planning
Commission should be granted subjects
conditions set out on page 73 of your
agenda
second gen
ugly thank you James thank you
we've got one speaker against this
application Joel Tucker
if you'd like to get yourself set watch
a second you've got three minutes
seconds
uh right good morning
I'm the owner of Bayview I know this is
only planning for the access but
some of the original plans forever
straps were actually protected my
property with woodlands so the actual
access is pretty Irrelevant for the
Environmental Center because my house is
already named to be protected by Woods
which they want to now protect build
environment so yeah the access is pretty
Irrelevant in my opinion
um there's multiple drainage problems
noise obviously right of um enjoyment of
my land and garden
um I purchased the original property
built it for my disabled child who's
sensitive to noise
in open Countryside hurt everything I've
ever earned into it
um and they basically want to try and
destroy it
[Music]
um
yeah it's just absolutely horrendous and
I will be fighting the environment that
said they're into my grave
it should not be being built there it's
open Countryside and it's just out of
order in my opinion
total chunk that's what we're not saving
thank you
yeah
that concludes your speakers now this
morning so James if you'd like to
proceed again and then
an openness for discussion discussion
Council Pennington so thank you chair uh
just looking at the 30 mile an hour sign
that is a Titanic Lane
composed that 30 door sign has moved up
above
display because we obviously
be uh safer for all rules from that
point of view if this is approved
so they can lay in the slight to the
west of you you know
just
on the edge of the right hand I'm
drawing the second thing is worth 30
million dollar signs are specifically on
the bigger side of the new development
yeah thank you guys there be um so on
that issue the um the police officer
didn't get on my face at all or
um advised that that sign would be to be
reviewed I do understand though that if
that was a conservative member is that
that could be carried out and certainly
the highways Authority Under
um their separate legislation do have
powers to remove that um Street
Furniture or Street signage anyway so
that that certainly don't care not have
it removed but have it to me sorry yeah
to the east of the access road as you go
on towards Gallatin
yes as I said the highways Authority
without the powers to do that under
separate legislation of the highways act
so they can discuss that with them if if
members did feel that I was a particular
issue then then we certainly could
include a condition on the position well
I would certainly propose that we
request that from highways which we
approve for the application share
Pennington Council Christie yeah you see
that it's a bit of a Town Council
approved this uh we we understand why
it's needed and we clearly did go to
this
um there's a couple things I would raise
firstly if you look at on page 66
there are three structures just to the
north of that none of which have
planning permissions
I've just checked there is no planning
Vision so those at all and I wonder what
our offices if they can look into that
but the other thing is yeah the
gentleman there mentioned Woodland
uh so first I've heard of this because
the officers tell me about this
thank you
this referenced in my um in your
office's report on page
70 and
um the residential ability section
section three
towards the top of the page there so
lots and lots of history on the adjacent
side relating to Evan's transport
a number of
um a number of plans on later
applications show an area of Woodland to
be planted but it would appear from
looking at the interrogating the
decisions associated with those that
they all relate to a much earlier
permission and they've effectively just
been used because they showed aside
propensity so so for example in in 2015
we had an application for plot three
which sits directly to the north of
um the buffet View Property so that's
that's an Evidence transport development
that that particular
um uh drawing shows Woodland there
however there's no conditions relating
to that from the agricultural report
doesn't relate to that Northern
landscape implants Etc so it actually
relates back to the application that
I've set out within your offices report
to 2007
um permission basically
and then that was extended in 2011. what
are the conditions on those required a
landscaping scheme to come forward and
it does appear that that's related to a
range of
um Landscaping matters to uh to
basically screen The Wider of evidence
transport development that there's no
evidence that those matters were ever
resolved through the submission of a
discharging conditions application or
something like that so effectively that
that is now time barred from enforcing
against it's obviously due to the time
elapsed since then there's very little
the council will be able to do about
that at this time pretty good
yeah I'm just reminding the committee of
course this is a temporary accessible to
the site
for once if um the environment Center
proposed for that site is built if that
gets planning permission this road will
be closed up onto Gallup road because
there'll be a new role proposed as you
can see in the outline there to come
into the top of the site
and whatever
sound or attenuations needed on the
border on the boundary with that if you
of course will be part of that education
and it comes forward
whatever it's deemed necessary on that
but we're just dealing with this
temporary application access to this
night to enable the development if it
gets planted official to go ahead
without having to wait for the other
room to be built into the sun
anybody else any wrong that comes to
Brown yeah the report that the access is
needed for the
um 600 Runners the new school that might
come forward and so the visual impact
would be only temporary so I would like
to go along with a grant for for
approval because once this construction
and we're just finished with it will be
returned to its original site I feel
sorry for the gentleman what we can't
consider Family Matters as part of a
planning so I'd like to recommend
approval please thank you counselor
Brown I mean it did occur to me this
rules on the other side of the site you
know as far away from Bayview as it
could be
um
and there are conditions in there about
terms of work on this
and so it's been proposed by a councilor
Throne to prove Council a lot I was
saying I'll councilor locks end in it
anybody else with any comments
the point about the 30 pound an hour
sign up
I don't think it's it's strictly
relevant to the access here because the
utility amount that they're saying
just indicates that stretching rules
starting now an hour okay I would draw
and it's a temporary access and once
it's been known as though
I don't think I don't think it's
necessary
it's been proposed and certainly
regardless can you just hope itself
thank you Jack answer about him
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
of your agenda
and
I'm going to handle the microphone to
heaven
this this obviously relates to the
budget would appeal and the inquiry took
place back in back in September we've um
end of September actually
relatively quick turnaround in terms of
receiving the decision
um members will be aware of the position
that was reached on this in terms of the
alternative
um indicative plan that was submitted
um and the resolution of the
consideration by four councils how the
council should defend and reforge the
appeal so there were just a couple
points I was going to highlight in in
the decision and you know happy to then
respond to any questions anybody might
have
um I think the inspector is very clear
both in the preliminary section and
throughout his consideration and then
indeed with the conditions he's imposed
in terms of this being restricted to 215
dwellings not withstanding the
description of development still saying
290
um there were two conditions that he he
has included
um one restricting the total number of
dwellings and another preventing the
development of the Northwestern parcel
of the site
um you'll see from reading it there's a
very detailed assessment called
landscape impact
um
linked with that and the the inspector
at paragraph 27 referred to retaining
the Northwest slope undeveloped and
recognizes that
um this would ensure development would
not form a bold or approximate new Urban
Edge to to benefit now the the
committee's reason for refugal
um was under the Tilted balance that
landscape arms a key element from it and
I think this does actually enforce the
reasonable approach that the committee
took took in that regard
um that certainly would have been a more
obviously a more harmful landscape
impact but that as it is without that
part of being developed and the
inspected in the overall harm to be
moderate but does recognize the conflict
the policies of St protein and dmo8
there's a there's quite an extensive
discussion around biodiversity and
ecology again this whole development of
the refusal reason and the inspector is
satisfied with the condition to proposed
and considers the level of biodiversity
Net game which was least secured by a
condition to be
um significant off the proposal
um that then goes on to some discussion
around by the land Supply and pro CST 21
part two it's interesting that the
inspector does recognize this being a
site that was considered as part of the
schla and the part two of policy s part
two of um St 21 and the supporting
textures recognize that that the
approach taken that if sha sites are
obvious ones to come forward under that
route
um discussion around sustainable
location again that was something that
was highlighted by the committee
um the inspector considers this to be a
sustainable location for the various
reasons to search out with weight being
given to the winter allocation on the
other side of abortion rate
and again satisfied there is some detail
in there even though this wasn't part of
the refusal reason on highways and flood
risk the the planning obligation section
um
he he has concluded the built facilities
request isn't evidenced or some evidence
in terms of the council's Consulting
this is really disappointing
um as obviously we are very disappointed
by that however the important thing to
note is the inspector the doubles and
sufficient evidence to justify it not
that it wasn't
um Justified under policy that are
approached so some lessons to be learned
there moving forward and indeed he
didn't consider the early years element
of Devon County education's request to
meet the relevant skill tests as well
and that will be something that I will
pick up with them in terms of how they
may better justify that moving forward
um in terms of the the balance he he did
recognize the harm under policies sto6
st07 sp14 in terms of landscape and
dmoeta in terms of landscape
um but the harm attributed today's
policies was reduced due to due to the
provisions of XD 21 which allowed sites
to come forward outside of the
development boundary
um and in terms of conditions he has on
the most part agreed with the conditions
that were put forward of note our
conditions five and six in this and such
slightly unusual scenario where we are
restricting that amount of development
and preventing development on a named
parcel
um we have included a design code
condition on a few of our recent outline
permissions some of which have come
before you as counselors and the
inspector is deemed that that is
necessary he streamlined it a bit with
which I think does read better so you
can look out for that in the future on
any recommendations that come before you
um housing mix is something we always
include as a condition with reference to
a Hefner an old Target mix and it is a
bit disappointing that the inspector
deemed it just reference to housing mix
under the design code is sufficient
there's no specific reference there to
our evidence base which
um I wouldn't necessarily agree with Git
puts us in this robust position as we
would like
um yeah they were just some highlight
points that I wanted to bring to the
community's attention but certainly
happy to to answer any questions you
might have on it Angela Christie yeah um
I've already asked one question by email
this is the decision is it grants
permission for up to 290 houses
they can't come back later can they say
so oh that's what he said and here it is
in black and white that is definite
isn't it it is going to be 215. yeah so
the conditions five and six restrict
that that fake in terms of number of
dwellings but it also prevents
development that Northwestern parcel
um it just seems very odd decisions for
200 yeah it seems to contradict himself
anyway
um the second point is I presume they're
going to come back and we've got to look
at the section 106's again because
they're not going to have the same
number of houses so that's going to
affect their section 106. yeah so on
that point cancer Christie which is a
very valid point that matter was looked
at by the district value air
um so the application when it was
considered by the council the district
value air test for 290 and it reached a
percentage of affordable housing so due
to this change in the numbers and the
fact that they're actually a different
balance could be reached if the
different section 106 package the
district valuer did rerun their
appraisal so the affordable housing
percentage that's referenced in the
report is is a result of that updated
running of the DB's report which
actually increased I think the
affordable housing to 23
um in that in that time scale so the a
unilateral undertaking was signed before
the close of the inquiry
um which includes includes the various
Provisions that were put forward it does
include the built facilities and the
early years Devon County requirements
but there's also a clause which is quite
standard with the planning appeals that
says references the anticipated decision
unless you can be inspector Dean for any
of them are not necessary they're just
it's worked out essentially without
having to go in redo the section 106.
and the third point was um badges Hill
award itself
um it's just been reclassified by demons
ancient Woodland
and yeah when I looked at there is a TPO
a part of it and the part of it it runs
north south it doesn't you know you
would expect it it's a long thin
Woodland you'd expect it to be one part
or the other but it actually goes down
the middle which is I've asked for a TPO
to be extended on the whole of the
Woodland now because they're not going
to you they're not going to need to walk
through it so they won't have houses on
the other side as it were where's that
got to I'd have to check that for you
Council Christie but I can certainly
look at that and come back to you
directly on the market
Council along
I mean I I just wish that all the people
decisions came back as quick as this one
yeah
any particular reason why it came back
I mean potentially because of the
interact the sort of involvement prior
to the inquiry with very much focusing
those points of contention
um you know that said the inspector
still had to consider all the issues
um but probably possibly not in the
forensic way of having to balance
different sort of evidence that had been
given on a point so whilst it is a very
long appeal decision it's
um not necessarily as complicated as if
there had been a fun inquiry with
evidence being given on a range of
matters that possibly is why it came
forward quickly
foreign
[Music]
plan do not assist with these documents
or relevant extracts have not been
provided the same implies and inspector
sought some through a 3D artificial
quick provision do we need to do more
work on our side so that we can draw in
one or six monies for our structures
because it seems like there was a lot of
absent in here and then you know given
that we are now spending 10 pounds per
head for personal torch on our um
schools now surely you want to draw
money in from developers from that side
yes absolutely councilor Pennington
that's why I mentioned earlier this is a
really disappointing element of this
decision so
um we continue to secure contributions
under our built facilities calculator
which is sort of Justified under policy
St 23 so the build facilities calculator
similar to our green and structure
calculator
based on level of population to be
gained from a development calculates if
a contribution is required and secondly
then how much is required towards sports
awards Community Halls swimming pools
and artificial pitches
um it tends to be developments in our
main centers in Biddeford that that we
can't justify that now the position here
is that with a with a planning inquiry
there is a requirement to pull together
prepare a still compliance statement
and that should set out lots of evidence
in terms of firstly how that's been how
it meets the sales test eventually so in
terms of the quantity where it would be
where and how it would be spent and you
know in terms of geographic location and
I think the simple answer is that the
appointed consultant didn't didn't do
that to be extend required in this
element and I I think there's nothing
people to say on that really
um I think as officers we do go through
that exercise
um we are going to have a further
discussion in light of our own sort of
facilities just to be absolutely clear
on the monies we are securing the likely
time scales for those and ensuring that
they fit with the projects we've got in
terms of storage pool
um and potentially an artificial turf
pitch in the center of bitterfield so
there is a lot of work goes into it
cancer pendant I think the important
thing is absolutely to know to make sure
we're just dividing evidence in that
request certainly if you're in a field
process and 79 is Health okay
interesting comments about normal
surgery you're being over subscribed no
mention of bilafort Health Center and
given the two applications we had last
time at winsford
um quarterborough which Bay Pacific
under capacity at abersham Road
um whereas I just find this a slightly
contradictory that the inspector wasn't
even aware of the undercapacity when
we're given under capacity figures
previously
um all the previous applications yeah so
I don't have the consultation response
to the NHS to hands they they would they
have quite a detailed formula that they
apply and their catchment areas the
different surgeries actually all over
the line so they they look at that total
capacity and whether there's over or
under
um provision relating to the development
proposed
um so there's a there's a lot more
detail to this than what the inspector's
referencing here but I think the
important point is that he recognized
that there is permission in place for an
extension to the northern surgery there
is
um
and over subscribed until it's over
subscribed and turned to the patient
list and therefore in terms of the seal
testing the request that was being made
to do in our external ODS committee is
to actually help the Health Service to
account for how they're coming up with
their assessments like I tried to bring
that through our foreign plan for our
ons if I can because it's essential
figures for sustainability for the
future of our community giving that we
are an aging population
and also amazed agency in terms of
building and not Staffing because GPS
now are gathering nearly half the GPS
are ready to retire in the west country
at the present moment and we haven't got
the staff and people spend all the money
on the buildings you like but if you
haven't got the staff we need to see
another measurement in there that
recognizes capacity to actually see and
treat people really so I I need a better
measurement I think
country Chris is coming unless one of
the reasons I want to put it into
buildings there's the buildings around
by the doctors yeah and that is an
attraction that's one of the perks if
you've got a brand new surgery and the
doctors own them they could sell them
all yeah I mean that's that's one of the
reasons
right but I think
we're all disappointed at the outcome of
the appeal but the thing is
we turned down the original site for
very good planning policy reasons for
the 292.
and we said well the the applicant can
go to a bill if they want to do which
they did but what blindsided us was the
fact that the applicant then submitted a
fresh application for 215 which we had
absolutely no input to the inspector now
I didn't know there's nothing none of us
knew that the inspector to an appeal can
accept a separate application like that
and then so the the inspector accepted
the 215 application from the from them
we'd know him but to talk about not at
all to them we would have fought and
defended the 219. we were advised we
would have a good case to put on the
290. but we would have no case to put
really on the 215 which
surprised me really because in that 215
still was Badger's one which has always
been the contentious part
really as well as the visibility of the
high that that's been taken out to her
joining the link room but badges would
when I read through what the inspector
had said he just seems to to me to
dismiss
that all together because people are
still going to be able to walk through
it from this new development and they
talk about fencing off areas for badges
in there as we argued I think well I
certainly argued that the original
application for the two now did once you
build carriages there you didn't forget
the wildlife that resides currently in
the morning so it'll clear out and all
the children which I like them getting
out into the countryside and then join
the countryside they'll be playing in
those woods in the middle while
so I would you know and I'm disappointed
as Helen has said that the heart built
infrastructure would have had hasn't
come through a fault of not submitting
the documents in time I did watch some
of it on zoom and I didn't know what
they impressed with any of it really
but there we are councilor Christian
they've got to say one thing um the
reason I'm trying to get the TPO on the
whole Woodland is when they come back
for Reserve matters I'm going to ask
that they're fenced off
if it's an ancient Woodland it's
actually quite special so I will bring
that up later but the other thing I
think you put your finger on why we were
blindsided but I found the most
upsetting thing was I couldn't tell
anyone what was going on and I had so
many people contact me who were going to
appear at the inquiry were going to put
their cases and I couldn't say don't
bother you know um it was terrible
um I don't know how we can get around it
if if it ever happens in the future it
was really upsetting
um I felt quite guilty actually
of course I mean States it can elaborate
she wants to it was illegal sale
everyone was at the time I mean we were
right as as the plans committed to
insist that it went to full Council for
a decision which it did but that was in
part two because of the legal
implications while we're still well our
legal team is still in the guilty of
endemic image and coming to agreement so
and as Helen had said some of the things
were agreed on before the appeal and
that's what reduced the time that they
appear Council Pennington yes
discussion there's this no Southern
precedent that other developers when
they get their application reviews we'll
do the same principle they will plug in
for 500 instead of 400 and we're most
other presidents for for and not us but
the fun inspector and if I agreeing
that's not our work actually it's upon
inspected by agreeing is there a present
set here and have they working illegally
and do we have any right of judicial
review there isn't it's not a precedent
that said it is what the law is that
another meaning none of us knew it I
think that I've never seen it before no
I no I don't think any of those out for
the planning inspector obviously can
accept an alternative application on the
same site always obvious
I mean they haven't said she went into
that building
no you we've run through it Chad and and
I I do understand from Members
perspective how how disappointing that
is because as Helen's
I just said when the original
application was presented to plans it
was for the 290 scheme and you
considered it on a 2019 scheme and your
refusal reasons were based on a 290
scheme however the legislation does
allow uniform alternative scheme to be
put forward and the inspector has their
power to allow that I think what what is
a little bit unsatisfactory is have the
215 scheme come to members and you may
have
um based job reviews or reasons on on
different matters and I think that
that's that's what's a little a little
bit unfair and I can understand why
um you would feel discontentment about
that and I also understand from Members
perspective how difficult it is to you
know not be able to tell the public
um exactly what's going on but the
difficulty is is obviously if we put out
in the public domain what would attempt
to negotiate it it may Prejudice our
position when the developer so it is
really really difficult but it's
unfortunate we have to bear it in mind
in the future that's what can happen and
I think going forward you know make sure
maybe that's an element of decision
making because they're allowed to appeal
that you know
um and and maybe to have that but it is
always it's you know hindsight's a
brilliant thing I I think you know we
hadn't known that that was going to
happen necessarily so and I yeah our
hands are tied a little bit
unfortunately so
um I think the inspector it did go on to
say you know
how well thought our plans members had
had dealt with this and how sensible we
were during the appeal so I think you
know hats of terms if you hadn't had
refused
um the 290 scheme and I accept you may
not be overly content with the 215
scheme but it has gone some way to
addressing the concerns that were raised
and the refusal reasons that were put
forward up at plans committee so I think
it is achieved enough ultimately but
it's achieved
um most of the objectives members were
looking to set out
thank you thank you thank you officers
all right thank you we'll move on then
now to
199 on the agenda which is costs on the
cruise and now I'm going to cost some
yields 10 is delegated decisions edgy MB
they're normal
11 on pages 117
223 are planning decisions listed list
of delegated planning decisions
and actually plans for committing
decisions constantly abbreviations and
application tax enclosed from the 22nd
of
September to the 20th of October they're
listed on pages only 117 to 123.
um councilor Pennington
read the page 120. and taking the whole
page
have amazed how much agriculture
um
it seems like there's similar
applications in there and my question
relates and I'm not going to actually uh
name the person but he didn't speak to
me earlier this week because everybody
else needs to get their application
his application was validated on the 2nd
of October 2nd December 2020 but it's
never been decided upon me after the
present moment and he feels very
unfairly treated how can I move that
forward because he's got the
environmental idea on his back saying
he's got to
um do something and it appears that to
England they're saying you can't do this
and he's caught between a very hard rock
and an impossible place to be and how
can we move it forward yes so um this is
a big issue at the moment it's you know
the requirements on Farmers to have
certain agricultural infrastructure in
place by certain time scales pretty much
being pushed by the environment agency
but then the the requirements under
Wildlife legislation
um in terms of impact on protective
sites that Natural England are requiring
um habitat rare assessments and
appropriate assessments so it's an issue
we're very aware of and we're trying to
be proactive now so a meeting took place
last week um
with some of my colleagues involving the
environment agency Natural England bmfu
um which was very productive
um so we are we're just looking at how
how better we can inform and work with
Farmers so if you want to separately
give me that reference cancer Pennington
like I can certainly have a look at that
and speaking to the next question I see
that East Adam though have stopped
normal development and all foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not sure why you know in terms of
libraries unlimited Southwest I think I
think this one was slightly unusual and
that often the fridge is actually within
a community building but in this case
they needed permission because
a shed was being put up to then house
the French so it is a little unusual but
becoming quite a common feature because
that's just the address isn't it because
it was really temporary yeah the
application yes
it obviously to each agreement with the
libraries I think that's where it's site
is yeah yeah okay if nobody else has
anything on any those delegated decision
to move on then
12 is the exclusion that the public is
no need for that there's no part two so
I will declare the meeting close and
just from midday and thank you to all
the officers and everybody who's taking
part in the community thank you to
anybody for watching on YouTube